africa's most active volcano erupted a
week ago
in the east of the democratic republic
of congo the city of gomer was flooded
with lava and thousands of people were
forced to flee the area
now they're starting to return looking
for the remains of their former homes
and livelihoods
dw correspondent marielle muller reports
masika francoise lost everything her
house
where she lived with her children and
her family business
the entire life she had carefully built
up over years
consumed by flames in a matter of
seconds
we decided to flee hoping that lava
would not affect our house
but on sunday when we came back
everything was gone
we were left with nothing
she had no time to take any belongings
with her now she's living with friends
but could only take two of her ten
children the others are with neighbors
one here one there
it's making me very sad but there's
nothing i can do about it
like masika over 4 000 people have lost
their homes and their entire livelihoods
some of them found refuge at friends
houses or in nearby towns but now they
depend on humanitarian assistance in
order to survive
why was there no warning for goma about
2 million people live in the area
the director of the goma volcano
observatory says the world bank did not
renew the funding for their work
with no funds they were unable to
monitor the volcano properly
in october the internet was cut off that
caused problems
we have stations that are 150 kilometers
away
but then we didn't have enough fuel to
get there
when the internet is working the
observatory receives data from sensors
on the volcano every four minutes
for seven months that was not the case
everyone knew that we didn't have the
means that we worked with difficulties
but some volcanologists say there were
clear signs that the volcano could erupt
in the next few years
civil society activists say the blame
lies squarely with the government
and the gomer volcano observatory itself
those scientists of overhead if they
weren't corrupted
if they didn't spend money or projects
founded by world bank
they we could prevent the death
right now mazika isn't bothered who is
responsible
all she cares about is trying to rebuild
her life
there is nowhere else i can go there's
only one goma
there's only here for me to stay with my
children
like masika the people of goma live
under the shadow of one of the world's
most dangerous volcanoes
they can only hope the city will be
better prepared by the next time it
erupts